ANDREW PEARSON: Windsor Circle
is a retention automation
platform for retailers.
We basically help
retailers get more
from their existing customers.
We do this through
big data integrations,
through retention analytics, and
then by powering abandoned cart
recovery, and retention
marketing campaigns
to help them get more value
from their existing customers.
One of the real
problems that we aimed
to solve in the
very beginning was
helping marketers get access to
all this amazing data they have
about their customers,
products purchased, and so on.
And we thought that
once given the data,
marketers can do
incredible things with it.
Well, it turns out that many
marketers are incredibly busy,
some of this is new to them.
And so it was a really
important moment in our company
to realize that we actually
should wrap around the services
layer to make sure that
we provided best practice
coaching, and delivered some
of that extra value of helping
them to actually use that data,
and teach them how to do it.
BRAD MCGINITY: The first version
of Windsor Circle's pricing
model was one where
we just guessed.
We started at a thousand
dollars a month,
and if we thought
somebody might pay more,
we quoted them higher.
And if we thought they would
pay less, we quoted them lower.
From there, we were able to
then understand the return
on investment we were
generating for customers,
and really standardized that
into a formula where we've now
been able to ensure
that everybody
gets a great return
on investment.
And smaller customers pay us
less than we started with,
and larger customers
pay us more.